estelle hoffarth bonjour alors quelles
sont ces mesures justement qui ont été
mises en place par le gouvernement
depuis le début de l'épidémie pour
lutter contre le coc vie de 19
eh bien depuis le 24 mars dernier la
france est officiellement en état
d'urgence sanitaire et ce pour les deux
prochains mois de ce régime qui encadre
notamment le confinement et les
restrictions de liberté alors
concrètement d'aucune semaine les
conditions de déplacement des français
ont été durcies pas question de sortir
sans cette attestation sur l'honneur
dûment signé et daté depuis une semaine
également il faut a désormais indiquer
son heure de sortir puisque lé
déplacements sont limités à une heure
par jour on peut donc ce premier
promener ses enfants ou faire du sport
mais dans un rayon d'un kilomètre de son
domicile de son domicile et bien
évidemment tout seul parmi les mesures
prises par le gouvernement il ya aussi
est la fermeture à des marchés ouverts
ils avaient été pointés du doigt lors de
la première semaine de confinement car
beaucoup estimaient que le risque de
contamination
ils étaient trop grands sauf dérogation
exceptionnelle les marchés en plein air
sont donc désormais clos pour ce qui est
des déplacements pour motif médical même
chose les conditions enfants plus
strictes il faudra désormais à qu'il
s'agisse d'une urgence ou est rempotée
en possession d'une convocation d'un
examen pour tous ceux qui ne respectent
pas ces règles de confinement lalande
qui les guette à grimper elle n'est plus
de 38 euros comme au premier jour du
confinement mais désormais à 235 euros
et jusqu'à 1500 euros en cas de récidive
dans les 15 jours 3 159 milles pv pour
non respect du confinement ont déjà été
elle délivrait concernant les crèches
écoles lycées et universités ces
établissements son père mais vous savez
cela depuis le 16 mars les élèves ne
reprendrons pas le chemin de l'école
avant elle la fin des vacances de
printemps soit le 4 mai quand on
continue il devrait durer au moins
jusqu'au 15 avril prochain une période
qui pourra être prolongée est si
nécessaire en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie de kovy 2
19 je vous rappelle qu'à ce jour on
compte l 52 1128 qui a confirmé et 3163
décès merci beaucoup et c'est el farj
pour ces précisions quant aux mesures
prises par le gouvernement depuis le
début de l'épidémie